[Music]
death is not a problem for me I don't
don't really mind leaving
that's Tina Turner in 2018 already
admitting at the time she was at peace
but tributes continue to pour in as
those who knew her best are remembering
the legend
she was really sick and not wanting
people to know about it but you know she
had her dialysis machine in her house
and that's how she was doing it Tina's
close friend sheer suggested her death
was related to kidney disease and just
two months ago the 83 year old made this
Grim post saying my kidneys are victims
of my not realizing that my high blood
pressure should have been treated with
conventional medicine I have put myself
in great danger after a long illness
Tina passed away peacefully at her 76
million dollar Swiss home purchased less
than two years ago but Tina looked to be
in good health in 2021 for what would be
her last public appearance during this
taped Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
acceptance speech yeah this is mine only
I don't care if you know
back in 2017 Tina's husband Irvin Bach
donated one of his own kidneys to save
her life he came to me and said I can
give you one of my kidneys I said if
you're young I'm already older it's okay
her husband Erin Bach is the most
extraordinary person he literally willed
her to live
[Music]
this morning Oprah shared her memories
alongside Gail King while on vacation in
Italy she's been through one Health
crisis after another you guys know she
had a stroke she had cancer I mean and
she kept coming back she kept back
surgery just recently in February
[Music]
Beyonce who performed with Tina at the
2008 Grammys said quote my beloved queen
I'm so grateful for all the ways you
have paved the way
hey
[Music]
the baby
Angela Bassett earned her first Oscar
nomination in 1994 for her portrayal of
Tina and What's Love Got to Do With It
she tells E.T quote her final words to
me for me were you never mimic me
instead you reach deep into your soul
found your inner Tina and showed her to
the world it was the hardest role I ever
had to play I had to dig deep into my
spiritual core to show up and be there
100 every day E.T was on set of the
critically acclaimed biopic and this is
the exact moment Tina first met Angela
on set I never wore that
oh great when I met Angela she looked
nothing like me but she was likable I
liked her immediately and that was
important to me
[Applause]
[Music]
in 1985 E.T was behind the scenes
leading up to Tina's electrifying Live
Aid performance with Mick Jagger it's
like you have some pretty fun
companionship up there on stage it seems
like it doesn't it I made some good
choices in the last few years yeah I've
played with it we've been friends for
that I don't want to tell you how long
today the Rolling Stones front man
posted this rare behind the scenes
footage of them backstage together in
1969 and said quote she helped me so
much when I was young and I will never
forget her
of course Tina's Legacy and music lives
on and it's no surprise that her songs
have spiked in streaming in sales
what you want me